Littérature sans frontières,
Catherine Fruchon Toulousain.
Elle s'appelle Johanna
Gustafson, ses romans se
passent en Suède, ses
personnages sont suédois et
pourtant elle est totalement
française, mais son amour du
pays et de son mari ont fait
d'elle une écrivaine de polars
scandinaves à l'image de son
nouveau livre, l'île de Youl
qui se déroule près de chez
elle à Stockholm. Littérature
sans frontières, Catherine
Fruchon Toussaint. Demain à
partir de treize heures
trente-et-une. Rfi et France 24
présentent
Radio Foot International, le
Café des sports, Annie Gasnier.
Bonjour à tous et merci d'être
au rendez-vous hebdomadaire du
Café des Sports sur euh, RFI
sur France 24 et sur euh,
Facebook Live euh, tout ça en
même temps euh, et tout ça pour
nous suivre dans euh,
différentes dimensions. Nos
invités ils sont présents, le
le quatuor on va dire un petit
peu évoluer aujourd'hui mais il
est toujours là, lui. Bonjour
Rémy Ngono. . Bonjour Annie et
je retrouve en revenant. Voilà.
Oui bah, on va on va le
dévoiler avant mais moi
j'aurais voulu dire quelque
chose euh, Rémy la semaine
dernière avez dit que ça
faisait 10 ans que vous étiez
euh, mariés et vous ne saviez
plus euh, quel était le le
numéro de de le nombre ou le
qualificatif de ces 10 ans en
fait ce sont des nôtres d'étain
et regardez on a même retrouvé
les illustrations. Vous vous
souvenez? Waouh!
Ce mariage il y a dix ans, eh
ben voilà, on y était avec
Xavier Barré, avec Chérif
Alejandro, le on était
nombreux. Chérif
aussi derrière. Voilà. C'était
il y a 10 ans et on a pensé à
vous Rémy. Merci. Bonjour euh,
Chérif bonjour Annie, bonjour à
tous, c'est un plaisir. Merci
de revenir dans ce euh, café
des sports on continue à vous
entendre à Radio Foot mais
c'est un grand plaisir. C'est
un grand plaisir. Le café des
sports vous retrouvez Rémy en
face. Ah, il me manque Xavier
pour euh, pour l'électricité.
Il est il est toujours très en
forme oui mais Xavier euh pris
par d'autres occupations
aujourd'hui. Bonjour Benjamin
bonjour à tous. Tout va bien?
Oui ça va être calme. J'ai
surtout appris que Rémy m'avait
il m'avait charrié la semaine
passée parce que Naples était
sorti de la chanson. Je peux te
rassurer Rémy que j'ai pas pu
venir parce que j'avais passé
une très mauvaise semaine. Ah
ouais tu la remets parce que
c'est exactement comme ça aussi
avec Xavier. Il est toujours
occupé, pris quand le va mal.
Donc je t'avais bien dit que
n'allait nulle part. Bon voilà
très bien. On verra ça. Bonjour
Frédéric Suteau . Bonjour
Annie. Bonjour tout le monde.
Oh nos auditeurs, nos
internautes euh. Toulouse ils
sont tous là, ça commence à
arriver. Alors on nous demande
oui Xavier, est-ce qu'il est
parti danser, là il y a
quelques messages? Exactement.
Et puis on a un bonjour du
Suriname euh Alain Gouet,
fidèle auditeur, je vous écoute
depuis le Surinam, bonne
émission à vous tous.
Merveilleux. Waouh. Et merci à
tous de nous suivre à travers
le monde, d'ailleurs notre
session en carton hein, en fin
d'émission nous donne toujours
euh, l'impression de de voyager
grâce à vous. Alors, au menu de
nos débats, de ce Café des
sports, nous aurons la 106e
finale de Coupe de France
demain soir au stade euh, de
France, les Canaris d'Antoine
Kombouaré tenant du titre
auront l'opportunité d'un
doublé mais les Toulousains
rêvent eux d'un titre qu'ils
n'ont jamais remporté en tant
que TFC. Une rencontre sous
très haute surveillance
sécuritaire pour diverses
raisons notamment de des
supporters, véritables frères
ennemis. Newcastle de retour
sur le podium en Angleterre à
six journées de la fin du
championnat, les renversent
leurs adversaires en espérant
décrocher la Ligue des champion
ces en tout cas un bel exemple
à suivre qu'on se le dise et
vous saurez pourquoi.
Talentueux mais imprévisible,
Youssef Belaïli est l'enfant
terrible du football algérien
, le champion d'Afrique
deux-mille-dix-neuf ne prie
guère dans club où il passe, il
a encore disparu. Cette fois
d'Ajaccio, sans laisser
d'adresse, un triste gâchis
pour un joueur plein de talent.
Qui m'a aidé à préparer cette
émission? Pierre Guérin,
associé à Laurence Elernot et
pour tout ce qui est euh,
l'illustration vidéo, Yann
Bourdelat, Steven Eslie et
Mathias Toulouse le Café des
Sports, les débats sont
ouverts.
C'est donc la finale de la
Coupe de France prélude hein à
la fin de saison euh chaque
année. Cette Coupe de France,
star de la soirée au stade euh
de France, cet énorme trophée
argenté terminera dans les
mains ou du capitaine euh des
Nantais euh il s'agit du
gardien Alban Lafont ou bien
dans celle du capitaine de
Toulouse , Brest euh de Youger
si je ne me trompe pas. Le
capitaine hein euh le capitaine
des Violettes donc de ce euh
Toulouse Football Club. Une
affiche inédite que cette euh
rencontre au sommet entre un
club historique du championnat
de France et qui l'a déjà gagné
euh plusieurs fois euh cette
Coupe de France et puis il y a
euh en face euh une équipe qui
elle a été promue cette saison,
qui monte et qui descend et qui
est souvent plus connue pour
les résultats de rugby que de
football. Les Canaris tenants
du titre sont-ils les vrais
favoris de cette épreuve? Alors
à tous, je voudrais signaler ce
livre, cet excellent livre et
c'est pour ça que je vais lui
poser la première question à
Chérif Guémour, parce que
Chérif Guémour a écrit euh, ce
livre pour le centenaire de la
Coupe de France, c'était donc
en 2-mille-dix-sept. Euh, et il
y a un Nantais sur la
couverture d'Henri Michel,
capitaine soixante-dix-neuf de
la grande équipe euh, ouais.
Tout à fait. Euh, Chérif
Guémond, est-ce que euh, le
fait qu'ils aient gagné l'année
dernière euh, leur donne un,
peut-être un supplément
d'expérience et d' euh à ses
canaries ou pas? Absolument,
tout à fait. Alors c'est c'est
c'est intéressant c'est que
historiquement euh le football
club de Nantes c'est plutôt un
une équipe de championnat qui
pendant longtemps gagné souvent
le championnat et avec
l'histoire finalement c'est
devenu une vraie équipe de
coupe ils l'ont gagné l'année
dernière et euh il y a un début
de mystique qui s'est prolongé
cette saison parce qu'ils sont
pas très bons en championnat
ils sont ils sont un peu en
difficulté mais euh ça s'est
euh en en Europa League contre
la Juventus ils font un très
bon parcours et ça rani un peu
le la flamme des supporters, on
va en parler aussi je suppose
euh donc euh il y a un début de
mystique pour cette coupe et
ils la veulent euh je sais pas
si c'est le public qui la veut
le plus ou c'est l'équipe a
priori il y a une grosse
dynamique euh de vouloir faire
le doubler. Ouais, faire le
doublé et c'est c'est difficile
et compliqué de faire le
doubler dans cette compétition
hein Paris Saint-Germain l'a
fait euh ces dernières années.
Euh pour ce qui est de donc de
de cette rencontre sur le plan
sportif euh Benjamin Mokandjo à
qui l'avantage selon vous peut
au vu des effectifs, on sait
que il y a un joueur qui brille
du côté de Nantes, c'est
Ludovic Blas, il n'est pas le
seul, mais c'est vrai que c'est
un peu la tête de pont de de
cette équipe euh qui euh par
ailleurs attend difficulté euh
au quotidien dans le
championnat. Après si justement
on s'est fie au championnat, on
va dire avantage à Toulouse
parce que Toulouse marche mieux
en championnat. Mais maintenant
peu de vent, ils ont neuf
points d'avance ils sont sauvés
déjà ils ont 42 pour moi et je
pense qu'ils sont pratiquement
sauvés pour la pour la saison
prochaine. Mais je crois que
maintenant il y a aussi facteur
qu'il faut mettre euh qu'il
faut souligner, c'est c'est
l'expérience. On a dit tout à
l'heure, Nantes l'a déjà gagné,
Nantes dans son effectif a déjà
d'expérience, il y en a qui
l'ont gagné aussi et je pense
que ce côté-là va énormément
jouer parce que faut avoir joué
une finale aussi dans ma vie,
je sais ce que c'est hein quand
c'est la première, il y a
énormément de pression, on a
envie de prendre trop fort et
repartir à la maison et j'ai
peur que cette pression-là
tétanise un peu les
Toulousains, après ils ont un
super entraîneur que j'ai
connu, que je connais, que j'ai
eu aussi comme entraîneur, je
sais Philippe Montanier. Oui,
qui est un très très bon
entraîneur. Il s'est le qui va
tenir va être important mais
maintenant ça va être ressenti
des joueurs il faut tout de
suite entrer dans ce match-là,
ça va pas être un match facile
pour Toulouse mais Toulouse a
quand même de bons joueurs et
euh pour approfondir un peu on
voit que le recrutement de
Toulouse a été très très
intelligent aussi, a été très
très bien fait avec des joueurs
qu'on connaissait pas tous hein
moi je l'ai pour la plupart je
les ai découverts euh cette
année c'est un collectif ça
fonctionne ouais. Montagny a
souvent joué en trois quatre
trois là on voit qu'il a
changé, il est passé à 4
derrière. Quatre derrière. Donc
il y a aussi cet atout-là qu'il
faut mettre, il faut prendre
considération cette faculté de
changer le système en cours de
match ou même avant les match
mais oui je pense que avantage
quand même de par son
expérience. Rémy je ne peux pas
dire avantage à Nantes parce
que j'ai vu le dernier match de
Nantes. Oui. Comment on soit
quand même relégable? Trois.
Ouais. Alors je vois comment
est-ce qu'il termine ce
match-là? De faire match nul.
Oui de faire euh sept deux deux
là c'était vraiment euh Rigra.
Le but il est limite hein. Hum.
Il est limite. Il est limite.
Et puis je constate quand même
que cette équipe que je croyais
être réaliste manqué justement
de d'être clinique au niveau de
la finition parce que quand
même dix-neuf tirs où j'ai vu
pratiquement c'était euh
presque 80 % des tirs qui
étaient non cadrés. Alors
aujourd'hui quand je vois cette
équipe de Nantes, moi je me dis
oui vous pouvez dire que
l'affaire est un bon parcours
en Europa League, se faire
éliminer trois zéro aussi enfin
euh par la UV qui n'est pas
aussi une superbe équipe que ça
je vois cette équipe de nom qui
fait des prestations qui ne
sont pas aussi convaincantes
que ça. Pour moi aujourd'hui
cette équipe peut être surprise
par Toulouse parce que Toulouse
aujourd'hui est sûre de
conserver déjà au moins de
rester en ligue un. Or là le
problème de Nantes la pression
est double. Pourquoi est-ce
qu'elle est double? Parce que
vous êtes en seizième position.
C'est-à-dire vous n'êtes même
pas encore assuré de votre
maintien. Prenez-nous
religieux. Voilà. Premier nom
relégable. Et maintenant vous
êtes en train de regarder aussi
que est-ce que par rapport au
championnat est-ce que nous
allons faire ceci? Nous allons
faire cela à cette coupe nous
avons lâché ceci, nous allons
lâcher cela. Bon, à une
certaine période, je me dis
cette équipe de Nantes, ce
n'est pas véritablement moi.
J'accepterais que Nantes gagne
parce que il y a Castelet tout
le Camerounais qui est là-bas.
J'accepterais bien parce que
voilà. J'aime bien de l'or,
j'aime bien la forme qui au
garder des buts. Mais comment
véritablement ces dernières
prestations, elles ne sont pas
aussi convaincantes? Qu'est-ce
qui se passe dans la tête des
joueurs justement euh par
exemple euh Benjamin? Vous vous
en finale de la Coupe de France
qui est qui est une coupe
prestigieuse, qui est une
finale prestigieuse et en même
temps vous vous battez au
quotidien pour le championnat.
Est-ce qu'il y a un moment il y
a une compétition qui prend le
pas sur l'autre dans la tête
des joueurs? Oui, notamment on
parlait du match contre
Toulouse avant euh le match de
demain. Je crois que quelque
part ce match contre Troyes
dans la tête ça a joué parce
qu'il il préparait déjà la
finale. Moi je suis persuadé
hein. Je suis sûr ils se sont
qualifiés pour la finale il y a
aucun joueur qui veut rater une
finale, personne ne veut la
louper, tout le monde veut la
jouer. C'est ce que l'on
reproche qu'on mais il a raison
que de toute façon jusqu'à la
finale de la Coupe de France et
le et le danger le danger c'est
que si demain tu gagnes pas la
finale tu prends un sacré moral
dans la tête parce qu'il faut
rebondir derrière. Ouais c'est
vrai. T'es pas sûr de repartir.
Ouais. Frédéric ouais les on a
des supporters canaris hein qui
se manifestent là Chris Mbala,
les Canaris sont favoris avec
notamment leurs euh joueurs
congolais. Samuel Mutu euh qui
qui sera là euh Nantes va
encore nous dit euh Isodore euh
réaction encore là c'est un
petit clin d'oeil à Xavier
Barré, on sait que Nantes c'est
son club de le jour où Nantes
est en finale, Xavier n'est pas
là, il préfère aller danser euh
c'est bon signe pour Toulouse
euh Maxime euh encore, le
FCNantes est favori mais moi je
préfère voir Toulouse gagner
euh cette coupe. Hum. Donc je
suis le chat noir. Le chat noir
avec un livre et Henri Michel
euh qui soulève la coupe pour
Nantes un peu hein. Ah oui
parce que aujourd'hui quand tu
regardes l'équipe de Nantes,
honnêtement non ça nous faisait
rêver et moi j'ai bien peur que
cela puisse arriver, ce qui
justement était déjà arrivé en
2001, vous vous souvenez quand
même. C'est-à-dire que Nantes,
Biya également comme ça, il
venait d'ailleurs de gagner en
2-mille7. Il venait d'être
champion de France. Et en 2007,
ils se sont retrouvés dans une
et telle situation, de telle
sorte que justement, c'était la
relégation. C'est comme ça que
Nantes qui avait passé 44 ans
en première division s'est
retrouvée en deuxième division
parce que nous étions justement
le même cas d'espèce bien peur
de par rapport à ça parce que
Nantes c'est bien parce que
c'est quand même l'histoire de
la France avec des grands
joueurs que ce soit Didier
Deschamps, que ce soit des
dessailles que ce soit même les
Thuram qui sont quand même
passés par là et même qui sont
passés par là et même qui a
joué contre le Cameroun, ils
sont passés par là donc c'est
une équipe qui faisait rêver et
que j'aurais souhaité qu'elle
puisse véritablement comme
avant. C'est vrai mon ennemi
juré, Xavier n'est pas là mais
tout au moins au niveau de
Nantes. Ouais. Nous avons un
dénominateur commun. Euh Chérif
ce ce trophée il est il est
extrêmement beau, il est
iconique, c'est c'est vraiment
un énorme euh saladier comme ça
une un vase en je l'ai porté
hein, c'est très beau, c'est de
l'argent massif. Avec un un
socle euh oui et un socle en
marbre blanc, il date de 197 et
c'est le même depuis la la
création de la de la
compétition hein ouais ouais il
a un design un peu euh du début
du siècle hum Alors ce qui est
intéressant c'est que cette
compétition elle euh elle est
accessible finalement aux
petits et c'est ça qui euh joue
ce qu'on appelle la magie de la
Coupe de France. On sait que
euh les petits euh et ça ça se
joue il faut bien le dire, sur
un seul tour, ces matchs.
Ouais. Euh c'est il y a pas
d'aller de retour et c'est euh
sur la pelouse souvent quand
c'est des petits, ben on va
jouer chez les petits. Euh les
gros euh ne rentrent en en
liste 32e de finale mais aussi
sur des matchs uniques et on a
vu cette saison par exemple
Marseille se faire piéger par
euh par euh justement, c'est ça
la magie de la coupe.
Rappelez-vous depuis 10 ans euh
les coupes nationales, que ce
soit la Coupe de la Ligue ou la
Coupe de France, d'ailleurs la
Coupe de la Ligue a disparu
donc plus grand prestige pour
la Coupe de France.
Rappelez-vous ces dix dernières
saisons championnat, la Coupe
de la Ligue et la Coupe de la
France, c'était préempté par le
PSG. Donc euh il y avait plus
de intérêt parce que en plus il
a gagné ce moment. Et cette
année, le PSG a sauté, après on
s'est dit, bon ben ce sera
peut-être Marseille, Marseille
a sauté, on s'est dit bah ce
sera peut-être Lyon oui et on
se retrouve avec euh ben les
équipes les plus valeureuses
alors avec bon des fois il y a
eu des pas le PSG en finale et
ça fait quelque part. Donc on
se retrouve avec ces ces
équipes mais il y a toujours un
immense mérite, c'est d'arriver
à une finale d'une compétition
même quand c'est facile, même
quand on joue un club de
national, de CFA, il y a
tellement voilà qui se font
piéger donc euh ben gloire à
Toulouse et et à Nantes, on va
pas enterrer Toulouse quand
même non plus, comme l'a dit
euh Benjamin ? Pas du tout.
C'est l'équipe euh qui a une
cohésion? Et très régulière
très régulière, ceux qui ne
connaissent pas, ils être
étonnés parce que c'est une
équipe euh qui sait faire du
jeu, qui sait se montrer
dangereux, ce qui a des des
temps forts. On espère qu'on
aura pas la finale qui nous a
un peu frustré l'année dernière
euh donc euh voilà. Et ça
c'était terminé sur euh un
zéro. De derrière nous pour
ceux qui nous regardent de
cette ville justement Nantes.
Nantes qui s'est enflammée
parce que Nantes c'est une
grande ville de de football qui
a connu les ses heures de
gloire euh vous les rappeliez
Rémy mais c'était surtout dans
la fin des années soixante-dix,
début des années quatre-vingt,
quand il y avait ce euh cette
avec Saint-Etienne à l'époque,
c'était euh le Nantes et le
Saint-Etienne. Mais quand on
voit que que cette compétition
finalement euh comme le le
championnat est un peu euh
toujours attribuée au Paris
Saint-Germain et à raison euh
Benjamin ça donne un supplément
d'âme euh aux équipes et aux
joueurs quel que soit leur
niveau en se disant euh ben
peut-être que au moins on a un
trophée cette saison. Ben c'est
bien que ce soit partagé quand
même hein parce que dès lors
vous avez une équipe qui rafle
tout sur son passage, c'est
très compliqué. Mais le fait
que le Paris Saint-Germain
notamment cette année voit même
l'année dernière, se fait
battre par d'autres équipes,
ben bien sûr que ça crée et ça
crée euh euh dans d'autres en
d'autres club cette envie
d'aller jusqu'au bout. Donc de
dire que le le Paris
Saint-Germain n'est pas
imbattable. Le Paris
Saint-Germain, tout le monde
peut jouer contre le PSG et
gagner. Et c'est ce qui est
arrivé cette année, c'est bien.
Au moins la Coupe de France,
elle va tourner, peut-être que
demain elle sera Lens? À À Lens
ou ou même dans dans dans
d'autres clubs, bon il y a
Rennes aussi qui qui qui a
gagné, qui l'ont connu. Donc je
trouve que c'est intéressant.
Au moins, ça donne de l'espoir
petit club entre guillemets, de
pouvoir rêver. Non de juste
pour rajouter mais on voit les
images euh avec les vainqueurs
là qui qui soulèvent le trophée
il y a ce moment magique, c'est
une soirée, un match et on
soulève la coupe, vous avez
connu ça avec la la Can euh
Benjamin c'est irremplaçable
comme émotion, hein? Non mais
ça ça se remplace pas ça, ça se
remplace pas parce que toute
façon peut-être que c'est la
seule coupe que vous gagnerez
de votre carrière, moi c'est la
seule que j'allais gagner et
j'ai gagné la meilleure hein je
changerais pour rien même si
t'es même si t'es une champion
j'aurais pas changer. Mais
après les niveaux sont quand
même différents. Là on parle de
la Coupe de France, c'est un
trophée que tu gagnes avec euh
avec ton club, c'est différent
du trophée que tu gagnes avec
ta ta sélection. Mais ça reste
quand même valeureux, ça reste
toujours au mérite, au
méritant. Et je trouve que
c'est fort. Après on dit pas
quelque chose quand même par
rapport à Toulouse je pense
qu'il faut le dire, c'est que
si Toulouse gagne demain,
attention ils sont pas sûrs de
participer à la à l'Europa. Ah
oui! L'Europa League. Oui,
encore que Benjamin on va se
poser la question parce que
c'est une histoire de
propriétaire effectivement on
se souvient de ouais. Qui
faisait la compétition alors
que la faisait aussi. En plus
peut-être que en étant en ligue
conférence et en ligue euh on
on sait euh du football
européen. Aujourd'hui si tu si
si La Coupe de France néanmoins
c'est euh c'était pas la ligue
conférence. C'est c'est
l'Europa League. Oui. Donc vous
êtes susceptible de vous
rencontrer. Oui. Effectivement.
Et bon après ça dépend si euh
s'il a ses bilans. Il faut
changer les statuts. Toulouse
en 15 jours. Rémy en plus il y
a des les les belles histoires
ça peut être aussi celle de
Rennes, on se souvient, Rennes
qui réussit à gagner la la la
Coupe de France contre le Paris
Saint-Germain, parce que encore
quand le Paris Saint-Germain
est éliminé en route euh
notamment par Marseille, cette
saison et tout, mais il y a eu
des moments aussi très fort
dans ces finale. Oui parce que
il faut savoir que la Coupe de
France euh elle peut avoir euh
ce sentiment de pouvoir euh
faire la compétition entre
David et Goliath. Quand on est
devant, et c'est pour ça que je
dis que attention Toulouse,
même si Toulouse n'est pas
seulement euh le David, parce
que Toulouse au niveau des
prestations devant Nantes, mais
néanmoins on se rend quand même
compte que euh beaucoup
d'équipes préfèrent gagner
enfin cherchent à gagner ce
cette équipe-là. Cette
compétition-là parce que même
quand Nantes était au sommet,
même quand Nantes était au
sommet, je dis bien que Nantes
pouvait avoir des
internationaux mais Nantes n'a
pas gagné la Ligue des
champion. Nantes a eu beaucoup
de participation. Mais vous
allez voir que pendant ce
temps-là, Nantes, avait quand
même réussi à gagner trois
coupes de France. Et par la
suite, après sa descente en
deuxième pour revenir chercher
à avoir ça. Nantes aujourd'hui
c'est que on regarde son
effectif et de ses moyens ne
peut ni prétendre à la ligue
des champion
la Coupe de France comme le dit
un proverbe africain mieux vaut
manger une tête de lézard que
de courir derrière une tête de
lion. Ah un petit message euh
macluya, carton vert à Benjamin
qui nous dit qu'il changerait
pas une canne pour une Ligue
des champion
Euh
dans les traditions aussi
bien ancrés euh de de cette euh
fête euh du football euh
français au au stade donc
demain soir, c'est la présence
du président de la République.
Alors c'est lui qui remet
traditionnellement le trophée
au capitaine des vainqueurs et
le premier à lancer euh cela,
eh bien c'était Gaston
Doumergue euh et tous les ses
successeurs d'ailleurs l'ont
fait. C'était le 8 mai euh
mille-neuf-cent à l'époque, il
l'avait remise au capitaine de
Marseille qui s'appelait Ernest
Claire. Emmanuel Macron sera
bien là, il l'a annoncé en
dépit des remous sociaux dont
vous parle l'antenne de RFI ces
derniers temps et euh il les
les les services de sécurité
bon euh sont un peu sur des
charbons ardents mais du coup
le président a annoncé qu'il ne
descendrait pas sur la pelouse
euh pour saluer les les
effectifs avant le coup
d'envoi. Euh quand euh quand
euh aux critiques euh il y
avait des syndicats qui
promettaient d'y distribuer des
cartons rouges hein c'est ils
font comme nous des cartons
rouges et des sifflets avant
euh le match mais euh
apparemment ils seront
interdits, ça vient de tomber
par un décret préfectoral
autour de l'enceinte donc ça
devrait émettre moins de gra
par contre ça va être un test
aussi euh, et ça euh, Chérif
parce qu'on est à 500 jours
euh, ou un tout petit peu moins
euh, des Jeux Olympiques, il va
y avoir aussi la Coupe du monde
de rugby en France et on a
quand même tous en tête dans ce
même stade et il y a un an,
c'était la finale de la Ligue
des champions euh, qui s'était
très mal passée, qui avait été
très mal organisée, d'ailleurs
là on promet 50 % de plus de
forces de l'ordre, il devrait y
avoir 3mille , trois000 flics
ou gendarmes. Ben oui, ça avait
été en désastre aussi bien au
niveau de l'organisation que
niveau de la communication
après, c'est c'est surtout ça
que les médias étrangers euh
qui ont été très durs, hein,
beaucoup plus dur qu'on ne le
pense euh c'est pour les deux.
Hum hum. Pour la mauvaise
organisation, tous les troubles
qu'il y a eu, on va pas revenir
là-dessus. Et ensuite la
communication euh qui
supporters de Liverpool, on on
va pas revenir là-dessus. Le
football français euh passe un
test euh demain euh il faut que
ça se passe bien. Jusqu'à
présent ça se passait bien
cette Coupe de France mais euh
je sais pas si on va en parler
euh il y a des Bizbys entre
justement entre voilà. Le
problème il est là euh c'est
que on a eu euh des finales de
Coupe de France bon enfant et
puis euh des fois avec euh
certains clubs euh il y a des
antagonismes euh euh que
Saint-Etienne euh Nice enfin il
y a vraiment des des des entre
Nantes et Toulouse et Toulouse
ouais ouais ben j'ai j'ai j'ai
j'ai j'ai toujours été surpris
parce que bon à la base euh il
y a pas un antécédent
historique comme il y a pu y
avoir entre Marseille, Paris,
euh Lyon euh Saint-Etienne, des
trucs comme ça, il faut en
tenir compte et euh faudra que
ça se passe bien euh je pense
que l'U FA, on verra un ou deux
délégués pour s'assurer que
tout s'est bien passé Et après,
bon ben euh on se retrouve
comme vous l'avez dit, avec euh
la la Coupe du monde de rugby,
où la France joue aussi euh
passe un test. La finale sera à
suivre sur RADIO avec Martin
Guez, hein, qui sera dans le
stade euh de France, et en
studio, il y aura Hugo
Moissonnier et Ludovic Duchêne
à partir de dix-huit h
cinquante7 en temps universel.
Nous on continue.
C'est le retour au plus haut
d'un club historique en
Angleterre. Newcastle est sur
le podium de la Première League
et à quelques journées euh, six
exactement de la fin du
championnat d'Angleterre, ce
qui nous fait dire eh bien que
ça peut sentir très bon pour
ces mags. Ils avaient commencé
fort hein en début de saison,
on se souvient, ils étaient
dans les premières passes,
après ils ont quand même
nettement reculé, mais les
revoilà et en grande forme au
meilleur moment, en plus euh
ils viennent de remporter deux
victoires assez marquantes euh
au cours la semaine ils ont
battu Everton c'était euh hier
ou avant-hier soir et ils ont
battu Everton sur le score de
quatre à 1 et puis il y avait
eu euh le week-end dernier ce 6
à un infligé à Toulouse est-ce
que euh ces euh euh Benjamin
Mokandjo vous semble euh
revenir d'abord en haut au bon
moment et il vous semble une
équipe solide? Oui je pense que
le recrutement a été très très
bien fait. Quand on voit les
joueurs qui sont arrivés.
Ouais. Très précis ouais
exactement Chérif avec qui sont
arrivés. Je pense qu'ils ils
ont quand même connu une
descente il y a une année
descendus il y a pas il y a pas
assez longtemps et je pense que
le fait d'être descendu ça a
remis toute à plat, ils sont
partis sur un nouveau projet
avec de nouveaux joueurs, avec
de jeunes joueurs aussi, des
joueurs valorisants, des
joueurs de de qualité bien sûr,
qui se sont vite intégrés Oui,
qui a mis euh qui a mis ce
qu'il fallait, qui a mis ce
qu'il fallait, mais je trouve
que même avec cet investisseur
qui a énormément d'argent, ils
n'ont pas fait de folie
Absolument. Ils ont pris des
joueurs qui correspondaient à
leur façon de jouer avec un
entraîneur qui est très bon.
Moi j'ai eu la chance d'aller
les voir euh en finale contre
Manchester en finale de la Cup,
j'étais j'étais à Wimbled, j'ai
trouvé que c'était une équipe
très solidaire, très soudée
avec des très très bons
joueurs. Et je pense
qu'aujourd'hui c'est pas le
fait du hasard qui se retrouve
la la troisième place. Parce
que comme le disait bien à Nice
ils ont commencé depuis le
début de la saison, on s'est
dit que c'était peut-être un
petit coup de paille, ça allait
durer un moment, après ça
allait s'éteindre. Mais on voit
que même quand ils traverse des
moments difficiles, il dure pas
longtemps réussissent à
rebondir derrière et moi je
trouve que c'est un le choix
ont été bien fait, ils ont pris
Guy Marech, que je trouve
extraordinaire
c'est une équipe oui oui. Et je
trouve que c'est une belle
équipe moi elle me fait fort
impression et je pense après je
peux me tromper mais elle
aurait pas volé hein c'était
une troisième ou quatrième si
l'année prochaine elle aura pas
volé cette place-là. Rémy
est-ce que pour vous euh les
effectivement euh arrivent mais
surtout vont réussir à s'ancrer
parce que c'était un peu la
qu'on se posait et à rester
dans le Big Fort qui est euh
évidemment euh un un cercle
fermé et très prisé dans le
football anglais. Jusqu'à
présent on avait des habitués
qui euh plus ou moins euh
montaient descendent ces
derniers temps. Euh là et on a
City Arsenal, on a Manchester
United et puis on a Newcastle
qui euh s'y invite finalement.
C'est l'équipe qui a la plus
grande progression en
Angleterre parce que quand on
essaie de regarder euh on va
quand même se dire que l'année
dernière et je le maintien. Au
début de la saison et tu as le
maintien. Oui oui il termine en
onzième. Ouais. Déjà un exploit
parce qu'on disait que juste le
maintien. Et puis vous voyez
l'heure où plus grandes stars
qu'ils ont eu à recruter
c'était finalement euh euh
Isaac, Alexandre d'ailleurs. Où
ils ont mis
soixante-dix millions et les
gens se disaient mais attendez,
ils ont beaucoup d'argent avec
les fonds suédois qui sont à
500 milliards mais eux ils
n'ont pas fait comment ils sont
allés progressivement et c'est
une équipe qui s'est bâtie
d'abord défensivement.
Aujourd'hui c'est la meilleure
défense, avec seulement 26 buts
en euh encaissés. Et lorsque
vous regardez d'ailleurs les
statistiques, vous vous rendez
compte que cette équipe n'a
perdu que 4 fois. Que Arsenal!
Comme Angleterre c'est vrai que
même quand ils ne sont pas
capables de gagner, ils te font
des matchs nuls, ils tiennent.
Ça fait de telle sorte que ils
ont aujourd'hui onze match
nuls. Mais lorsque vous
regardez, pendant que nous nous
étions en train de dire que
voilà qui est trop défensive,
regardez justement
l'humiliation qu'ils ont
infligée. À Toulouse voyez
comment est-ce que Toulouse a
dérangé Arsenal? Hier. Alors
mais Toulouse devant eux
c'était de la bouillie si hein
mais c'était cinq zéro à la
mi-temps. Donc cette équipe
elle est très dangereuse
d'autant plus que elle a de
l'ambition à long terme. Hum
hum. Et justement vous avez
parlé aussi de l'entraîneur.
C'est qui est anglais, mais qui
surtout a un contrat à longue
durée. Et quand ton entraîneur
a un contrat à la longue durée
parce qu'on l'avait vu
justement en Angleterre
pourquoi est-ce qu'on l'a
choisi? Parce que regarde
Ghemmour comment est-ce qu'il a
fait monter Bordeaux?
C'est-à-dire que c'était en 4e
division. Il a pris 6 ans pour
que Bordemi revienne à l'élite.
Donc c'est pour ça qu'on l'a
choisi. Et on savait
pertinemment que derrière ce
projet ou d'ailleurs l'Arabie
Saoudite quand même la coupe du
monde de
deux-mille-trente-quatre, ils
se sont dit nous allons essayer
de construire progressivement
et de venir mettre pierre par
pierre afin que telles des
abeilles qu'on puisse obtenir
du miel. Donc aujourd'hui
Newcastle c'est véritablement
quelque chose qui est de très
merveilleux. Euh Chérif
justement euh Rémy parle de
long terme. Oui. Et évidemment
ce qui vient tout de suite à la
tête euh c'est et on euh on l'a
évoqué avec aussi Benjamin il
n'y a pas eu de dépenses euh
folles et surtout de sommes
dépensées le prix de Isaac mais
peut-être un des exemples on se
souvient quand ils ont pris
Ghemma Race et pour sauver
première saison. 15 millions.
Est-ce que c'est un exemple à
suivre une leçon? Parce que
finalement eux travaillent sur
le long terme et on pense tout
de suite à Chelsea, Chelsea qui
avait recruté aussi son
entraîneur. Sur le long terme
qui a recruté avec euh des des
sommes absolument phénoménales
onzième, ils peuvent pas rêver
de Big Fort et du coup on se
dit euh c'est c'est aussi
intéressant alors on met un peu
plus de temps c'est plus
construit alors que Manchester
City et Arsenal cette semaine
ont apparemment plié le
championnat. Oui oui. Bah ils
ont ils ont procédé de façon
euh méthodique. Alors déjà on
va on va quand même repréciser
que cette saison il y a la
débandade de Liverpool et
Chelsea qui n'étaient pas qui
n'étaient pas prévues donc
forcément ça a créé un appel
d'air mais là tout le mérite en
revient à Newcastle il y avait
une opportunité ils se sont
engouffrés on est tous d'accord
autour de cette table. Il y a
eu des investisseurs saoudiens
qui à l'automne 2021. Donc un
an et demi. Voilà c'est ça. Ils
ont procédé de façon
méthodique, ils sont arrivés,
tout le monde a dit oh là là
ils vont des milliards, pas du
tout, ils ont mis tout le monde
hein. Voilà c'est ça. Quand ils
ont dépensé
3-cinquante- millions. Voilà.
Transfert. Quand ils sont
arrivés à la treize. Ils ont
d'abord Et le truc Chelsea
c'est le doute surtout. H. En
en une saison. À chaque jour
recruter comme l'a dit bien
Benjamin c'est le joueur qu'il
faut au poste au poste
spécifique Ils sont pas allés
chercher des des euh des des
des voilà. Pareil pareil pour
Toulouse donc ils ont pris les
bons joueurs qu'il fallait euh
au au au bon poste sans
surveillance Newcastle c'est un
club historique de la Premier
League, il y a un public, il y
a un stade mythique avec un
public le peut-être l'un des
plus chauds d'Angleterre. Donc
ça a été ça. Et surtout
l'intelligence des Saoudiens,
enfin des des actionnaires,
c'est d'avoir mis un entraîneur
anglais qui connaît le football
anglais au moins pour
commencer. Il est pas allé
chercher un entraîneur
argentin, espagnol ou italien.
J'ai rien contre eux, mais
c'est d'abord comme un mec qui
vient des secondes divisions,
des divisions inférieures qu'il
connaît parfaitement. Et c'est
pareil pour l'effectif.
L'équipe type de Newcastle elle
est composée majoritairement
l'équipe type un, de joueurs
anglais. Pas que j'ai quelque
chose contre les joueurs
étrangers, mais surtout quand
on arrive et qu'on veut se
maintenir en Premier League
avec des joueurs de caractère,
des joueurs qui connaissent le
championnat, qui vont vous
faire une bonne saison pour
commencer, c'est ça? Ils ont
pris des Anglais donc euh que
personne avait trop ciblé euh
et en fait euh c'est les
calomes où ils c'est les les
enfin tous tous ces joueurs-là.
Ce qui fait qu'on a une équipe
que de référence voilà qui est
très cohérente. Comme vous
l'avez dit, ça devrait être un
exemple à suivre pour pas mal
d'Angleterre et la dernière
chose que je voudrais dire,
c'est que il faut pas être
naïf. C'est jusqu'à présent, il
y a pas beaucoup de stars qui
sont arrivées parce que ça
manquait d'attractivité. Ils
étaient pas en Ligue des
champion. Hors ce qui va se
passer c'est que là
vraisemblablement ils sont ils
sont troisième, quatrième,
Toulouse est loin derrière pour
la cinquième place. Ils vont
très certainement jouer la
Ligue des champions et là avec
des moyens United même s'il ne
va pas très bien. Ouais. Un
match en retard. Oui bien sûr
oui oui ils peuvent finir
Manchester tout n'est pas
encore à partir du moment où on
est en Ligue des champion au
niveau de l'attractivité et
c'est peut-être cet été qu'on
va commencer à avoir euh. Oui
mais c'est pas tu te qualifies
en Ligue des champion il faut
relativement le changer. Non
mais tu peux le garder mais
automatiquement ça c'est sûr.
L'équipe quand tu vas en Ligue
des champion il faut renforcer.
Ouais. En fonction des témoins
de tes besoins. T'es obligé.
mais maintenant tu prends pas
un joueur, tu fais pas comme
Chelsea ils ont pris des
joueurs parce qu'ils voulaient
prendre, parce qu'ils ont vu
que le joueur il a joué dix
match, il était exceptionnel,
il y en a un, il a fait une
Coupe du monde merveilleuse,
allez cent-vingt-millions, on a
mis sur la table on l'a pris,
justement. Ben moi je trouve
que il faut avoir une bonne
stratégie et pour le moment ils
ont une bonne stratégie.
Justement, Benjamin quand t'es
quand t'es quand t'es quand
t'es un joueur à fort
potentiel, aujourd'hui tu vas
où? Tu vas à Chelsea ou
Newcastle ? Aujourd'hui? Moi je
vais pas chez moi je vais pas
chez Chelsea. Tu vas pas à
Chelsea
t'as un stade sublime, t'as un
public fantastique l'équipe va
jouer en Ligue des champion
par cette équipe de de
Newcastle euh Arsène Noubir
bondisque vous venez de dire
euh Chérif un club historique
demeure un club historique,
bravo à à Newcastle euh ou
c'est Newcastle Newcastle un
exemple à à suivre, venger,
carton vert pour la performance
des cette saison, ils font
mieux que le Barça euh qui sera
pourtant en Canaris bon au
passage quatre-cent-cinquante
minutes on est tous contents
pour Newcastle et l'adaptation
fulgurante d'Alexander Isaac le
suédois son slalom regardez ça
c'est la passe décisive de
l'année. Il y a les buts de
l'année qu'il a mis hier c'est
enfin la passe décisive
derrière euh. Cinquante mètres,
le ballon euh. Signalons,
signalons pour ce qui est de de
ce fameux match entre Newcastle
et et Tottenham que les joueurs
avaient écrit un message sur
les réseaux sociaux après ce
match. En gros en s'excusant
auprès des supporters et
surtout en promettant aux
supporters qui étaient venus à
Sainte-James Park de rembourser
et leur place. Allez, on
continue et on va parler d'un
joueur algérien euh un peu euh
enfant terrible.
De Youcef le plat du pied. Et
c'est Belaïli qui libère donc
son équipe. Porter disparu,
Youssef Belaïli ne répond plus
à l'appel de son club l'AC
Ajaccio, pourtant dans la belle
ville d'Ajaccio en Corse. Le
milieu de terrain algérien euh
sacré vous l'avez entendu, il
jouait alors avec euh ses
coéquipiers euh Fennec euh
champion d'Afrique en 209 est
absent de l'entraînement depuis
mercredi. Il aurait été vu à
l'aéroport euh de la cité corse
euh de la cité corse du sud
mardi soir. Alors peut-être
pour rentrer à Oran et euh
selon euh d'autres euh
informations venues d'Algérie,
ils seraient euh avec sa
famille puisqu'il aurait perdu
euh un proche de sa famille. En
tout cas euh son club a décidé
hein de de porter euh de
d'ouvrir une procédure
disciplinaire contre lui
puisqu'il n'est pas présent. Il
avait bien commencé euh la
saison. Mais Rémy est-ce qu'on
peut comprendre un joueur euh
comme ça? Je crois que j'ai
regardé il a fait 10 clubs
professionnels, il a 3-1 ans
donc en gros trente-et-un ans
quand même hein. Euh il a fait
euh bon il y a les les euh le
hum le S de euh de Tunis. Où il
est resté assez longtemps et
puis les les clubs algérien et
depuis euh il est venu en
Europe et là il s'est un peu
perdu. Je crois que c'est un on
appelle ça il faut invoquer du
gaz. Saint-Erita pour les
causes désespérées. Parce que
pour lui c'est très grave.
20-quinze il avait 23 ans on
disait que c'est parce qu'il
est trop jeune lorsque
justement c'est un test où on
on constate le après on se dit
quand même que il a la
possibilité de rebondir et tout
et tout. Mais regardez partout
où il est passé. Il a arrêté ça
c'est terrible quand on euh. Et
tout ça à Angleterre ça n'a
jamais été ça et c'est-à-dire
que vous le voyez il a du
talent on essaie toujours de
lui donner la deuxième chance.
Puis la troisième chance puis
la quatrième chance puis la
cinquième chance et finalement
il ne saisit jamais une chanson
même Beladi je crois qu'il
devrait aujourd'hui être
fatigué parce que ah il était
dans la dernière fois il a il a
convoqué mais qu'est-ce qu'il a
fait? Mais bien évidemment il
est resté, il n'était même pas
blessé, il a envoyé
l'échographie pour dire bon il
semble que j'étais blessé et
tout et tout, il n'a même pas
demandé l'autorisation du club.
Le club a été d'une indulgence
incroyable parce qu'ils ont
besoin de lui. Ah oui, ils ont
besoin de lui. Pas le choix. On
ne peut pas aussi avoir besoin
je peux vous dire ça. Parce que
à part les six premiers matchs
où il inscri les quatre buts.
Qu'est-ce qu'on a vu? Il est
sur pouvoir alternatif. Donc
pour moi aujourd'hui à 31 ans
ce monsieur il y a un proverbe
africain qui dit on ne dresse
pas un arbre tordu à tout comme
aussi un autre proverbe
africain peut nous dire vous
avez beau laver le corbeau il
ne deviendra jamais blanc comme
la colombe. Deux proverbes on a
un corse on a vu l'arbre tordu
euh peut-être c'est le le
corbeau posé sur l'arbre tordu.
Si j'ai bien compris Rémy
Benjamin Non je trouve que
c'est c'est un gâchis. C'est un
gâchis parce que c'est un
joueur talentueux comme Rémy le
disait à juste titre. On ne
remet pas en cause de son
talent. Hum. Maintenant je
pense que quand on est un
joueur il faut une certaine
forme de discipline. Ben quand
on est professionnel on a vu
aussi on a même des exemples
aussi hein dans le passé des
joueurs qui étaient voués à un
avenir euh glorieuse euh mais
finalement ils ont échoué. Oui.
Balotelli. C'est des c'est des
joueurs qu'on citait
régulièrement pour le talent
qu'ils avaient. Adrien. Mais
pour moi je dis la discipline
okay est par soi-même, mais il
y a aussi le respect de ses
coéquipiers parce que avoir un
comportement comme ça tu
respectes pas, tu te respectes
pas et tu respectes pas tes
coéquipiers. Moi si je suis un
joueur avec dans un effectif,
avec un tel joueur et si il
joue en occurrence, moi ça va
me déranger, ça me dérangeait
parce que j'ai le sentiment à
moi de tout faire, d'être à
l'heure à l'entraînement, de
respecter tout tout et à côté
de moi j'ai un joueur qui est
jamais présent, qui a toujours
une excuse de gauche à droite à
qui on on accorde une seconde
chance, une troisième, une
quatrième voilà, j'aime pas moi
j'aime pas taper sur des
joueurs parce que j'ai été un
joueur, je me mets à sa à sa
place mais je trouve que là on
peut pas défendre ce genre de
comportement. Ah oui c'est
vrai. Ce qu'il y a ce qu'il y a
de de de regrettable
dommageable, alors déjà il a 31
ans, c'est plus un gamin donc à
31 ans, c'est s'assumer quand
même. Ajaccio a fait des je
dirais pas des sacrifices mais
bon on l'a accueilli euh
vraiment pour le relancer et au
début on y a cru, il a fait des
des bons matchs. On comptait
sur lui quand même cette saison
pour descendre. Voilà pour ne
pas descendre, pour qu'Ajaccio
ça me maintienne et il y a eu
euh bon maintenant on sait que
c'est un feu de paille mais sur
le euh pendant un moment ils
sont sortis de la la zone
rouge. C'était six quatre
passes décisives quelques
semaines. Voilà et euh bon ben
voilà l'espoir renaît et
pardon? J'ai dit il pouvait
faire plus
de buts. Il y a déjà une
première fugue donc c'était euh
fin non début avril pardon qui
est qui est qui est qui est mal
passé. On lui a pardonné club.
On l'aurait jeté. La dernière
chose que je voudrais dire
c'est très important, c'est
l'importance du football en
Algérie. Les joueurs algérien
qui jouent à l'étranger c'est
toujours des ambassadeurs. Eh
oui. Toujours. On en avait
parlé avec le Brésil hein quand
avec l'exemple de Raï dans les
années quatre-vingt-dix, il
représente c'est un
professionnel et c'est lui qui
ensuite ouvre la voie à tous
les joueurs brésiliens.
Aujourd'hui on a un maraise,
c'est un professionnel sur le
bout des ongles qui est
reconnu, admiré. Heureusement.
Euh on attend la même chose euh
des autres parce que il y a
d'autres joueurs euh surtout
ces temps-ci, il y a beaucoup
de enfin beaucoup pas mal de
joueurs algérien qui sont
arrivés en en championnat de
France, en L 1 et en L 2 ils se
doivent quand même de euh avoir
une certaine exemplarité.
Frédéric c'est vrai qu'on hein
euh on le disait rapidement
mais il y a eu d'autres
exemples qui euh qui ont ont
été des gâchis du football
justement par manque de de
sérieux en fait. Oui ben c'est
les certains des noms qu'on a
prononcés euh à Tempé Arfa hein
qui avait un talent fou euh
mais qui finalement quand on
regarde le palmarès il y a pas
grand-chose et puis pareil euh
passé 25 ans il est passé de
club en club et à chaque fois
c'était problématique hum.
Partout où il passait. Ouais.
Malheureusement. Et donc euh
ben ces joueurs euh ils ont
vite dis euh ben oui Balotelli
qui était quand même un un
grand espoir, bon lui au moins
il a disputé un euro et il a
été euh un peu plus loin.
Allez, on en on est arrivés euh
déjà euh on s'approche de la
fin de l'émission et donc euh
nous en sommes au carton.
Carton jaune. un carton jaune.
Ouh là là là là, carton rouge,
carton rouge. Dans la
confusion. Carton vert.
Extraordinaire. Rien à dire. Il
y a les nôtres mais il y a
d'abord les vôtres, sélectionné
par Pierre Guérin. Bonsoir
Radio Foot International, c'est
moi Belaïa en RDC. Double
cartons vert, le premier à la
police de Turin qui a pu
identifier et sanctionner 171
personnes auteur des cris
racistes contre Romelu Lukaku
lors du match Inter contre
Juventus du 4 avril. Le
deuxième est pour la fédération
italienne qui a gracié le
joueur suite à l'exclusion
survenue après sa célébration
jugés provocantes. Merci et
bonne émission à vous. Bonjour
bonjour radio international moi
c'est la capitale du Tchad je
donne un carton rouge à mon
équipe du coeur le Real Matic
pour sa contre performance
contre Gironde l'Atlético de
Madrid s'avance dangereusement
de la deuxième place et comme
de dit Rémy
là je vois que le Real Madrid
est en train de perdre aussi
l'ego.
Le mec a vu à qui on nous fait
croire qu'il est fini. malgré
il joue au moins deux minutes
que les autres euh euh ou
les mecs quand même heureux
c'est une superbe fin de saison
en mettant 8 billes cette
saison à et cinq passes
décisives. Faut admettre euh
qui ne soit pas les élus qu'il
mérite. Très bonne émission à
vous Madrid. Radio Foot
International, ici le dessert
XX
accepte que garder l'état chef.
Bonne émission à vous. Merci.
C'est Ibrahim depuis la
Mauritanie mon carton
aujourd'hui est vert et il est
destiné à pour le travail qu'il
fait à Manchester City depuis
qu'il est là-bas. Il a réussi à
transformer cette équipe en une
machine de guerre qui nous
procure toujours ces jeux
pétillants qu'on veut tous voir
s'il est pelou. Et s'il y a
aujourd'hui un entraîneur qui a
bien révolutionné le football
moderne c'est bien lui. Donc je
pense qu'on doit tous rendre à
César à ce qui appartient à
César. Merci bonne émission
Bonsoir Radio Foot, bonsoir à
tous. Ce soir je donne un
carton rouge aux Ghemmour pour
leur mauvaise prestation en
première ligue. Voilà encore
comment la coupe est en train
de leur échapper. Dommage pour
vous. Merci. Bonjour ici depuis
le maire. Je donne un carton
vert à qui est en train
d'abattre un travail formidable
avec son sixième de la première
ligne, quand il prenait
l'équipe, l'équipe était
seizième. Vraiment
félicitations à une mairie.
Merci à lui et bonne chance à
lui. Salut
je donne un carton vert à
Newcastle il est actuellement
troisième de la première ligue
et il fait une très belle
saison. Les cartons verts à
vous, continuez comme ça. La
ligue des chemins 2024 on sera
là. Salut Sénégal. Carton rouge
aux dirigeants du FCN pour leur
projet sportif incompréhensible
pour leur politique de
recrutement incohérente et pour
leur changement entraîneurs
incessants. Aujourd'hui,
Chelsea est éliminé dans toutes
les compétitions auxquelles il
était engagé cette saison. Et
dire qu'il y a deux ans, le
club était champion d'Europe.
Carton rouge, et vive le
changement à tous les niveaux.
Salut à tous qui me
reconnaîtront. Bonsoir Radio
Foot International, mon nom
c'est Aboubakar depuis
Cameroun. Mon carton il est
vert, il va directement à
l'ancien joueur de mon pays,
Benjamin Mokandjo qui vient
maintenant chaque vendredi dans
cette émission, qui donnait
Rémy Ghemmour chapeau à toi
Benjamin bonne émission à vous
tous. Eh ben voilà, Benjamin ça
y est, vous êtes euh
apparemment euh intégré et
approuvé dans notre euh dans
notre groupe. Mais alors où
sont euh Hortense, Espérance et
Diane hein et vos copines, on
veut aussi les les cartons
féminins. Euh Benjamin à vous
la parole euh puisque vous
aviez un carton euh vert de la
part d'un auditeur. Oui, mon
carton il est vert, il a
attribué à Kevin de Bruyne. Je
vais pas faire long à Annie
hein. Vous savez il y a
différents types de joueurs, il
y a des joueurs qu'on a qu'on
adore, on admire, qui nous qui
nous montrent qu'ils ont du
talent, semaine après semaine,
mais il y a d'autres qui vous
donnent du plaisir Après ce
match contre Arsenal, je suis
parti me coucher avec du
plaisir parce que Kevin de
Brune, il m'a procuré du
plaisir. C'était l'homme du
match. Ah ouais. Hein? Et sans
sans doute euh futur champion
d'Angleterre. Euh nous avons un
un carton euh alors là on
change de couleur avec Rémy
vous revenez à vos amours.
Rouge. Je dois l'apporter.
Hein? Non président du FCN vous
vous rendez compte ce monsieur
a laissé partir Messi et
subitement. Il a recupillé un
lot de joueurs et maintenant il
veut faire partir ces
joueurs-là. C'est pas lui qui a
fait partir Messi hein. Mais
attends, soyons sérieux. Le
gars il liquide maintenant, la
télévision du Barça et
maintenant il dit que il veut
vendre Eric euh, il veut vendre
qui encore euh, tous les
joueurs qu'il a acheté. Mais
attendez, pour faire venir un
papa de trente-six ans. Mais
soyons sérieux et il y a un
proverbe à Afrique parce que
Tessier est là. Mais Tessier
n'a que 25 ans ou 26 ans, 26
ans, mais vous faites venir
Messi, 36 ans et il y a un
proverbe africain qui dit si
ton s'est échappé construit au
moins l'enclos pour conserver
tes moutons. Chérif carton
rouge à Alexander Séphorine euh
qui sept semaines a déclaré de
façon un peu si biline que il y
aurait peut-être une
éventualité que des matchs de
Ligue des champion à commencer
par la finale soit disputés
vers en 2025 aux États-Unis.
Alors euh c'est deux-mille2cinq
c'est aussi l'année de la
nouvelle formule de la Ligue
des champion on est pas encore
dans la super ligue parce que a
priori il est contre mais on y
va pas à pas. On guettera ça
dans Radio Fouse International.
Frédéric Carton vert, on
parlait de la Premier League et
puis un auditeur là qui nous
parlait d'Unai Emery, Aston
Villa. Il est arrivé en octobre
pour remplacer Steven Girard,
ça allait pas du tout euh, il a
mis un peu de temps et là ça y
est, c'est parti. Sur les dix
derniers match c'est huit
victoires, deux match nuls euh,
la Ligue des champion n'est
n'est pas si loin. Et puis on a
Emery on se moque souvent de
lui un petit peu, il est passé
à Paris, à Arsenal euh, mais
partout où il passe, il fait du
bon boulot. Ouais et euh, ils
seront au moins en Ligue Europa
euh, ils continuent sur leur
lancée. Le carton de Radio Foot
International est est attribué
à Pelé. Alors pas directement à
l'ancien joueur Rémy à l'ancien
joueur euh footballeur euh
brésilien, le grand joueur
décédé le 30 décembre dernier.
Mais à l'entrée de ce mot dans
euh le dictionnaire Michaelis,
qui est le le dictionnaire de
la langue portugaise dans les
noms communs. Parce que euh
désormais eh bien la définition
c'est que c'est être synonyme
d'excellence euh d'exceptionnel
ou d'incomparable. Par exemple
on dit il est le du basket-ball
où Rémy est le Pelé de euh du
Café des Sports. Vous savez que
en en France on a euh être le
Poulidor de quelqu'un hein, ça
veut dire être le numéro deux.
Voilà. Et sur ce, eh bien euh
nous sommes euh les pelés de
vous tous j'espère, et c'est la
fin de cette euh émission de ce
Café des sports. Bon week-end à
tous.